in order to unpack what we're talking
about here by um unordered selections
let's uh let's rewind a little bit and
let's call on the knowledge we know
about ordered selections by the way we
had a fancy name for ordered selections
we call these permutations right
permutations where the order is
important okay so for ordered selections
we might ask a question like this
what's the number of ways to permit to
arrange where order matters three
objects where you have five options to
choose from
now at this point we've been dealing
with questions like this enough that we
can go straight to an answer we could
call on our arm and you specialized
notation what will we say will be the
first number that we wrote down if we
have five options we would say oh you
could ask so you could draw the box I
rode 12 walks in a minute actually boxes
but we we know that the boxes are just
kind of a conceptual framework to allow
us to work out the number but we can
just calculate the number right we can
use our calculator and what would we
puncture into our calculator for this
question
hmm
yeah very good 5p3
right you've got five things to choose
from you want to choose three of them
and we use this pay for permute or four
pick that's actually sometimes how
people read it five pick three or
whatever and in fact I want you to go to
your calculator now could you tell me
what 5p 3 is equal to I'll wait till
everyone get there because you will
under your calculus
okay now you should find it's equal to
60 right now
this is actually a small enough number
it's why I chose this for us this is a
small enough number we actually could
have done that by hand if we remember
what 5p3 actually means do you remember
it's it's shorthand for a a bunch of
factorials do you remember what's in the
photo is there in a fraction okay very
good so in this case in this case the
the n factorial will be 5 factorial up
on the top okay
and on the bottom yeah this is gonna be
5 take away 3 factorial right so this is
equal to 5 factorial on 2 factorial and
this calls back the boxes that arian was
reminding us of right why would we have
5 factorial divided by 2 factorial well
if you've got 5 options and you want to
choose 3 of them here's our box 1 2 3
options the first time or sorry 5 3
objects and the first time you've got 5
options to choose from then the second
time you've got 4 options to choose from
and 3 you can see where this comes from
right so happy times this all makes
sense hopefully you remember this ok now
I wanted to think about what does this
actually look like in terms of an actual
question ok so for instance I might ask
you to form a three letter word you know
word write a three letter word from the
letters a B C D and E okay there are
five options to choose from
okay now you might think well this is
why we have these things for I don't
want to like
all of this out because that would be a
really time-consuming and slow way of
doing things when we talked about
probability earlier on we said you
should list things out only as a matter
of sort of last resort or if it's a very
very simple question okay but there's
something I want to illustrate for you
that you kind of need to see all the
options in front of you in order to
understand so here are all 60 of the
options okay now if you have a look
right this is three three-letter words
and you can see I've got a b c d and e
to choose from okay and can you see that
there are 60 there are you happy with
that six by ten okay now I want to use
this as an avenue for understanding not
ordered selections but unordered
selections suppose I reframe this
question and said how many ways can I
just choose not permute not a range but
just pick out three of those objects
from the five options
what if order didn't matter now if you
have a look at this you might be able to
tell I actually had to write these out
ad to work out what they would be could
written a program I supposed to do it
but I figured it'd be quicker just to
write out the 60 options but I wonder if
you can see I've done them in a logical
way to make sure I didn't miss any and
didn't double up on any when I put
together the original 60 I wonder if any
of you can tell just by looking at this
sort of grid how I've done it it's not
random at all what do you see here very
good if you didn't catch that when I go
from left to right for example just look
at the top row right these six up here
all of the options using a B and C okay
if you have a look all of these ones you
never see a B and C together all the
same time and I do that for every row in
fact mm-hmm each one of the rows
represents the choice of three letters
right and then you just permit them
right you just rearrange them and then
you choose a different three and then
you rearrange them and so on does this
make sense okay so if I want to say how
do I go from this question where order
matters to a question of what if order
doesn't matter see all these six options
these six up the top they're all the
same choice aren't they they are
all the same three letters right so this
is all identical all of these all
identical it's the same three letters
over and over again okay so now if I
rephrase the question I'd like you to
rephrase it with me okay
if I now asked you what's the number of
ways to choose three objects from five
options where order doesn't matter I'm
even going to write that right
how many ways to choose you could also
use the word combine because when you
combine things like in a salad the order
doesn't matter right you just kind of
throw them in the bowl and there they
are
right how many ways are there to choose
or combine three objects from the same
five choices and this party means order
doesn't matter okay well I can move from
the solution that we form to four and I
can kind of tweak it to get to the
solution that I need right I can say
well you start with this is my number of
ways you start with this 5p3 that gives
you all of the options there okay but do
you notice that if order doesn't matter
I have drastically over counted right
because all of these guys are the same
so I've ever counted by a factor of six
on this top line in the same way by a
factor of six here all the way down
right so in other words I've got six
times as many ways than I want so I
should divide by 6 to get to the actual
number does that may serve let me say
that one more time kids a bit tricky
right
I have using this over counter I have
six times as many different ways as I
actually want so to get to the answer
that I need I will divide by six right
that will sort of compensate for the
fact that I've over counted does that
make sense okay now I'm going to push on
this a little bit why is it six where
does this six come from can anyone tell
me think about it
so no way yes a infinite six I'd love
you to alright this ending right is
exactly as Filner says it's not just a
random number it's
three-factor now I'm gonna push on that
again why 3-factorial why should that be
important to this situation hmm
I have a thing what do you reckon
decadent okay so when you look at these
three objects right and you can
literally see it in front of you okay
you've got three choices for that first
one then two choices for the second and
one choice for the last one so every
rearrangement is well they're all the
same like it's the same three letters
that you chose so that's why it's 3
factorial it's the number of ways to
arrange 3 objects okay now if we take
this guy and remember that it's actually
shorthand for this factorial stuff okay
let's see what happens when I put this
into like when I actually expand out my
5p 3x that's just an abbreviation right
I've got 5 factorial on 2 factorial
that's the top divided by 3 factorial
from us fixing up the other counting
okay but fractions of fractions that's a
bit gross isn't it let's fix this up and
just create one fraction that 5
factorial will still be on the numerator
and on the denominator what will I have
2 factorial 3 factorial now hold on a
minute do you recognize this we already
have notation for this we introduced it
to you last year or almost more than it
won't no more than a year ago actually
what's our notation for this yeah this
is not 5 P 3 this guy this is 5 C 3 now
we didn't introduce this guy in the
context of probability or arrangements
at all where did you meet this what
topic is it from this is from binomial
theorem right this is the binomial
coefficient okay now at this point here
I could just stop and just point out
that's kind of cool that they seem to be
the same thing but if you're like me you
want to know why like doesn't that drive
you a bit crazy like why should this
thing which we introduced a long time
ago and haven't thought about really for
a while except for when we reintroduce
the topic at the start of the term why
should it come up
yeah okay